that he felt old when he was you know a
minute ago and I just thought I'd just
stop it David just stop it but this is
going to be an awesome match and we have
some moves David yeah and it's the
Queen's Gambit accepted uh that is an
acceptance of the gambited porn it's
just temporary Sacrifice by white uh the
porn the White Sea porn has disappeared
Magnus can regain that pawn back he will
gain it back but uh this is something
levon's been doing throughout the last
few months it's quite a new addition to
his opening repertoire surely Magnus is
prepared Magnus just taking a pause
there pushing his Pawn forward White's
light squared Bishop is going to come
out now and Gobble up that pawn again so
the gambiter pawn has been regained and
still very standard stuff this is a very
well known position
tens of thousands of games if not more
have occurred in this position
throughout chess history and Magnus even
had this position earlier in the
tournaments as black so what will he do
now
plenty of moves white can trade a set of
Pawns so I can bring a knight out push
them pawns himself lots of options
yeah I'm also curious to see what he's
going to play I've noticed it's very
trendy at the minute to actually not
touch the knight in the on the left side
of the board and instead to focus on
developing the dark Square Bishop
you know white needs to at some point
bring those three pieces to life on the
Left Flank and flat needs to do the same
black needs to get castled sometimes in
this type of position if we imagine
White's born in the center trading off
the black spawn those pawns disappearing
the Queens would be staring at each
other sometimes those disappear actually
Black's king is not that bad in the
center
it's uh yeah it's hard to cool it
depends on magnus's mood I feel right
now if he wants a quiet first game just
to warm up then we might see white
capture the black pawn if he wants maybe
a more tense game he'll develop one of
those pieces as your vacuum mentions
Simon how about yourself any experience
in this uh variation
um well we see him moved there and
played but I actually the only
experience I can recall recently is that
David I remember I mentioned that
position a second ago to you and I said
I've always struggled a little bit on
the white side of this and you you
recommended the plan uh that I should
play which I've totally forgotten now
but but I know it wasn't this bishop
move it's doing the center a very
aggressive plan but Donna give away my
prep anyways nothing doing my bad memory
yeah um but the move played is kind of
uh it's really sort of just waiting to
see what Black's going to do because
black normally
um advances his poor majority on the
queen side and White's Bishop light
Square Bishop is quite well placed to
meet that now so it's um keeping the
pieces on which I I'm I'm personally
happy to see and we see this Advanced
now occur and white often tries to get
his light Square Bishop attack and rook
in the corner that's what that's one
idea I know but maybe it's not so easy
to do and okay this is interesting just
pushing forwards in the center David
very aggressive actually and I must
admit I've seen this position briefly
before I think but I'm not familiar with
the ins and outs the both of them
playing very very fast pressure now on
the White Knight and it's a race
essentially if black can get castled if
Black's King can if the bishop can come
out and then the king can run away to
safety black is doing very very well
okay we see a trade of knights first of
all but black is still two moves away
from doing that and white has those two
Tempi two moves to create some nuisance
and he starts by undermining this black
pawn it's eyed up twice now the pawn and
Bishop so he has to commit it pushes
forward now however there is a Outpost
for one of White's pieces the white
Bishop can land here the White Knight
can land here and long term it's going
to be hard for black to challenge for
the square for example
it say white pushes a pawn and then
plants a bishop on the Square it's just
going to be a great piece uh long term I
wonder what Magnus has got in mind now
White's problems in this position are
his Bishop this bishop mainly where is
it going out I don't really see it uh
there is an idea I guess to sacrifice
the pawn and push forward in the center
but that needs to be well calculated or
well prepared and I have some
information on that particular Pawn push
that you highlighted because Lavon
aronian has actually played this exact
position with the white pieces and he
did sacrifice the pawn as David
highlighted and he actually won that
game it wasn't 2014. now what is the
betting that Lavon remembers this game
that he played with from the white side
and who was his opponent his opponent
was
and it was a blitz match in Beijing what
could Magnus I remember that game
unlikely right because it's a blitz
because you have to you tend to filter
her out those type of games and you
think well you know that might not be so
irrelevant but I wonder whether Lavon
aronian has a kind of photographic
memory of his own games because I can
tell you I I don't and I often I've
forgotten and sometimes I go back to the
database and I'm like oh my goodness me
I just play it into a game which was my
own game and I played brilliantly but
now I didn't play Britney but you don't
care that's why these you know these
guys are sitting there and we're sitting
here I'm afraid I mean because I have
the same problem maybe David doesn't but
I'm like yeah my memory is a bit of a
sieve nowaday I mean it's not that bad
but compared to these guys they have an
incredible memory it seems right I mean
like I know Magnus can recall games from
hundreds of years ago in really bizarre
events and uh their recollection of
games is is just it's another level so I
wouldn't be surprised if they both know
about this
um this this game
um wouldn't surprise me anyway so yeah
yeah there's different types of memory
the top players they tend to Remember by
experience magnet
if he remembers a game from hundreds of
years ago he'll remember oh I was
reading this one book this one time and
it was on this page which is already
freaky to me but most players they're
like oh I remember feeling a certain way
about this position and I think this was
the move and it might not be the kind of
complete memory it might be a bit of a
blur but I'm pretty sure aronian maybe
we have to ask him later but I'm pretty
sure ronian will have some recollection
at least of this position yeah I mean
he's moving so quickly um that he's
certainly prepared this position it's in
his is in his memory somewhere um so I'm
not so sure about magnusone I mean the
move that you suggested that Ivanka
looks looks very logical to me
um you're trying to get your last piece
into the game by freeing it up you're
trying to do something before black can
Castle do remember whites castled it
takes black two moves to get castle so
you should be trying to like home in on
your opponent's slight weaknesses and
and this is a weakness you know the king
could be a Target if we can open it up
so it seems like a very logical move to
me that that porn push I mean if he
doesn't do that I expect the game will
go to it will be quite equal I don't see
why black should be any worse if he can
Castle
it's more Magnus maybe to do some
maneuvering though like that maybe
moving the Knight around you know he he
prefers a slower game so maybe that pawn
push in the middle is not really his
style yeah uh in in this position it
would be a sacrifice so it would be very
brave but I can just take this pawn and
um I'm not sure exactly how White
follows up maybe bring the bishop out
getting some time against the queen but
then this would involve another Pawn
sacrifice The Black Queen could come and
take a pawn so this is the type of thing
going through Magnus is mine right now
he's weighing up the risk factor if he
gives away one pawn two pawns yes he
gets his pieces out yes the black king
is still stuck in the center it's a
Target but he needs to be 100 sure
before he sacrifices anything and if
he's new to the position as Simon
mentions maybe it'll be his Instinct
rather than push a pawn forward and be
brave and kind of gamble slightly
he will play a developing if we didn't
expect this how to say that is the I
mean I can see the point behind it but
that is the least expect I've never ever
you know I think that looks strange it
is strange it's really strong I mean
like what a move you know I mean it has
logic but what what is logic then please
show well I I think he asked yeah well
David can can show I guess here I mean
uh you're right Kyle normally Rooks
develop kind of across the board and
then they go up but uh here he's
developing it up one square because the
Rook was actually on this diagonal that
the queen sits on and he wants to push
the pawn next so for example if black
develops getting ready to Castle soon
then white will push a pawn forward and
uh if the Rook was still on its starting
Square the queen could come down swoop
down and take it but that's no longer
possible and actually The Rook might
develop this way to attack so actually
now it's looking kind of good now it's
looking good it's a swing assignment as
he is a swinger and uh I did check the
database to see if anyone had ever come
up with this kind of unusual idea and
someone did wow and in fact the reaction
from black was actually the castle Queen
side wow but love it yeah
come on do it live I was thinking you
know maybe if you don't want to gamble
like that maybe you could kind of get
the best of both worlds and put the Rook
there instead of the king for the other
side I mean one thing we talked about I
think throughout this competition and
other competitions is how do you beat
Magnus you know and the way to beat
Magnus is to go complicated try to
Castle on opposite sides of the board
attack him I would be like you know oh
he hasn't done it I'd be like you know
if you want to beat Magnus you've got to
you've got to try to unbalance it so I I
mean I was just hoping he castled but a
much more simple move on the board right
yeah is that the castling no longer
who's going to choose Queen side who's
going to choose kingside and who's going
to choose nothing at all I'll go
kingside
[Laughter]
that trick in your car I don't take the
boat
resting on my what do you say Laurels
yeah yeah yesterday nice glass of wine
coming
unfortunately after for example the
night trade and if white continues with
this plan and pushes upon forward
unfortunately here it's illegal to
Castle this way because you can't Castle
through track here the king would go
through a square that's covered by the
White Queen the White Queen so you would
have to spend a move preparing but for
example you could bring your Bishop out
threatening a Checkmate on this Square
uh this Pawn is not protected
sufficiently white could for example
block and now this would be the type of
scenario where we have the question I
think Simon's right most likely it'll be
king side he just feels safer with three
pawns protecting the king uh over here
perfectly protected here but uh if he's
feeling really fruity Really Brave this
move gets the rook in the game
immediately staring down at the
opponent's queen and the king is it that
bad I guess if you tuck it away closer
to the corner
so uh still some big decisions ahead but
the clock times do indicate that Magnus
is not comfortable Levon he's definitely
in his comfort zone yeah six more
minutes for Lavon Magnus is uh down to
less than nine minutes what does this
tell us about Magnus is he completely
out of prep and looking for something
freestyling I think already Magnus was
familiar with the first few moves I
guess but maybe he just didn't expect
this specific opening today Levon does
play a few things uh against the Queen's
porn opening nowadays
I think it's been out prepped doesn't he
I mean um in this game I think it's
clear just looking at the clock times
looking at the confidence looking at the
position even it seems to me that again
black I can't see why black has any
problems here I mean like his space
Advantage easy development
um I'm not saying Black's better but
when you're you know the first thing you
do with the black pieces is try to
equalize the game and then after you
equalize then then you can try to get
the advantage
and while we see him continuing his plan
here yeah yes David indicated yeah I
agree with you Simon I don't think that
black is better but you know then again
that is the goal in the opening when
you're playing the black pieces you just
want to get a position where your king
is castled your minor pieces have great
diagonals and uh well well well well we
saw a Checkmate being threatened and uh
the pawn stepped forward to attack the
queen now that's quite a committal move
I think because if Magnus manages to
consolidate his pawns and is able to
push those pawns especially in the
middle then he probably has an advantage
but if he doesn't then he's going to be
saddled with some with a very weak Pawn
on E3
yeah first he plants this bishop on this
nice Outpost that we talked about a bit
earlier this square that the bishop sits
on can never really be challenged by any
Black's pieces and uh now is decision
time heronian is going to Castle there's
nothing else really productive to do
it's just which side
I think both sides have pros and cons so
I mean more Pros to Castle King's item
but yeah on the right side I was reading
that tweet from don't care
it made me giggle about a black knight
that was stranded and you know had a cat
that was like go on without me
I'll just be here
nice one and if you two want to send us
a tweet then you can do so using the
hashtag chess Champs send us your
pictures your selfies your questions and
we will try and feature them on the show
yeah nice to hear your thoughts also on
the drama going on and Magnus speaking
yesterday if you do hope Neiman will
speak we do love seeing everyone in the
Chess World
get involved yeah and I think at this
point every opinion is valid right I'm
trying to reserve judgment until any
statements are made by another player
but
um yeah I mean more information comes to
like by the day it's fascinating times
yeah and it's a typical level neuronian
move he is getting ready for a fight
with some great opening prep in this
game yeah I think Lev's also won the war
game hasn't he I like his brick I'm just
like looking at Brick Wallflower that
looks so nice you know Lewis in the
chest houses is that right okay and I'm
looking at Magnus I think you know maybe
did you pay it up next time
you're not on TV mate you know just uh
you know I'm sure you can afford a maid
if you need to you know so I'm thinking
Lev's won the war game at the moment
definitely hands down hands down there
yeah I've heard it's a good philosophy
in chess to pretend you're a wall
sometimes just anything the opponent
throws at you it's just gonna bounce
back just your rock solid like nothing
can kind of destroy you nothing can
phase you just be a wall it's a good
idea isn't it be an immovable object I
think you've said you will not pass
isn't that your one yeah the Gandalf
approach that's kind of much more
passive you know I always kind of use it
if so your opponent plays like a very
very timidly and they're like literally
from the beginning go you're not going
to pass I'm going to just curl up into a
little ball more
yeah that kind of I mean but it can be
very successful and uh talking about
openings Muhammad Farah has a question
for us he says if you had to play one
opening for the rest of your life for
black and white what will it be
my question to you Simon
well I guess it would have to be for me
the Dutch and you can play The Dutch as
white which is called the birds named
after Henry bird so I'd have to go I'd
have to go Dutch Dutch opening yeah okay
I don't think it's that great all the
time but you know I have to pick
something uh David what about you I mean
uh can I guess you can guess Simon
you know my opening repertoire I think a
little bit reddish maybe you know so
that came to mind yeah yeah
you can play it with white you can play
it with black it's flexible do you know
what that's a really really good call
yeah the hippo I think would be up there
with yeah with the Dutch as well with me
very good cool I think I'd die of
boredom if I had to play the Berlin
every game yeah yeah this was the issue
I was thinking you know for me it would
be quite obvious would be the karakan
but I'm like do I want to pay that for
the rest of my life and then then I
thought about it I do play it
literally that is the only thing I play
so
um yeah so so it would have to be the
caracon with white
don't you have to play the same thing as
white and black that's what I thought it
was so yeah with white I have to go with
them see through one C3 yeah does it
have a name crap
language
one pound for every bad word yeah nobody
said the London system that would have
been instant uh but that's been you guys
talked about Trends uh lately London
system must have been a trend because I
feel that's the opening I've seen the
most yeah on the tour it's always very
popular isn't it at all levels the
London system I mean it's really popular
at Club level it's really easy to learn
and it's popular at top level so it's
actually a very good opening there's a
lot of memes though which uh try to
shame London system players because it's
such a good opening and uh meanwhile
Magnus is trying to go on the attack
look at where the White Queen has placed
herself
she's aggressively well she's basically
declaring to the black king that she
wants to attack and that black king
shuffled into the corner out of the Gaze
of the White Queen and now White's Rook
did indeed swing across not the most
active Square this white Rook has just
moved to but but he is Magnus now
supporting the pawn in front of this
Rook he wants to propel It Forward Push
It Forward Why didn't it go to the D
square instead you're right Kai uh I'm
surprised as well
um I think in this last position so
Magnus has just brought his Rook across
all the way to itu but he had the option
to move it to a different square right
now it doesn't work because uh you
actually block your Bishop's defense of
this pawn and this Pawn would suddenly
drop the black queen would swoop down
and this wouldn't work if it wasn't
check because white could win the black
Bishop but unfortunately for white it is
check you have to waste a move and then
the queen can kind of do a smash and
grab and take a pawn and run away
um so I was surprised though that he
didn't prepare this Magnus for example
could have either defended this Pawn
first or moved his King into the corner
and next try to enter the open file I
think you're right guy this is very
natural this is the best file of the on
the board for the Rooks but uh Magnus
wants a different plan he brings his
Rook across and this is why chess is so
complex so rich and full of possibility
because all these different plans
they're probably all fine it's just
choosing one being consistent and the
plan now is to push this Pawn forward if
possible I wouldn't be surprised if
Levon either stops this plan by plonking
his Bishop in the center uh this bishop
looks like it's doing a great job now of
just controlling both sides of the board
and it stops that white plan which is
always nice it's fun to kill your
opponent's ideas or you could maybe push
this Pawn forward
hit the White Queen also preventing
White from Ever pushing a pawn forward
to the square but this one is committal
once the White Queen moves now white has
a great diagonal for his Bishop my one
fear for Levon is that White's Bishop
will land on this diagonal the dark
squared bishop and the light squared
Bishop controls this diagonal and that
does mean trouble that spells trouble
for the black king huh so long term
black has to be a bit uh a bit careful a
bit wary in this position and it's very
interesting on the clocks Magnus almost
10 minutes down on the clock
I mean
has spending that much time should he
sort of have a bigger Advantage typing
at the bar 0.2
ideally you want maybe a simpler
position this one is still really
complex with all the heavy pieces on the
board so you want a simpler position if
you don't have too much time I'm always
in time trouble myself and I want to
simplify things make sure I can handle
it even with a minute or two left or as
you say Kai you want an advantage uh
something kind of a safety net but
Magnus he is known as a bit of a slow
starter the first game of the day he's
often just warming up and we did see a
big view on there
I don't know you know at first I really
like lavon's position I was like oh wait
no he just plays one of those moves that
David suggested I think it's fine but
then I started looking at it I was like
hang on a second that dark Square Bishop
that black has it's such a bad piece and
uh yeah he's gone for that pawn push but
I didn't like this upon second thoughts
because of this uh lengthening of the
diagonal for white stock Square Bishop
yeah I mean I I agree I mean that that
piece is horrendous and the other
problem I can see here for black even if
you know it's roughly even according to
the computer is that you really want to
play and this is a great tip it's not
just about the computer assessment you
want to play positions where you have an
easy plan you know no matter what middle
game this is now into the middle game
you've got to know exactly what moves
you're gonna be trying to do for the
next 5-10 moves you want easy squares
for your pieces to improve you want easy
plans and why it's got kind of easiest
plants I mean you can move that Bishop
he can take over the open file and it's
a little just I'm just trying to think
if I was in love shoes and this is a
great way to look at positions just what
do you actually do you don't have any
pawn breaks okay Magnus hasn't got many
but the only plan I can see is what
leb's doing just try to put your Rooks
on the open file but I can't see any way
to improve that bad bishop or blacks you
know how can you ever get that to a nice
diagonal I can't see any other Pawn
breaks it just it just seems a little
bit tricky to formulate a plan I mean
saying that also I have to admit
magnus's plan is not entirely clear to
me in the long run here but it's it's a
strange position you really get
positions just with Bishops on the board
as well so it's quite peculiar I might
be throwing the H Pawn up the board here
if I was Magnus at some stage trying to
use this one to to force some weaknesses
in my opponent's position
um but I don't know maybe a little bit
easier for white to play yeah uh exactly
a little bit easier and that's all you
need actually at any level especially at
the top level you don't want your
opponent to have a clear-cut plan and
Rapid chess as well and it's always nice
to have some idea what you're doing okay
the bishop steps back clearing this path
for the black Rook BlackRock controls
all these squares but it's not coming in
and Simon you predicted the future well
great minds you know you know what they
say so it's quite worrying when Magnus
plays a move that I recommend actually
basically twins
and I think yeah okay more exchanges
there I mean it's lots of things
happening very quickly David now aren't
they yeah wow and look at this by Magnus
the Bishops did just leave the board and
Magnus doesn't hesitate he pushes
forward
what's the idea here this Pawn can be
captured just take it and take it yeah
white will take back this is a
deflection tactic that what black queen
is overloaded she has to protect this
square if she moves away and takes the
white Rook then whoops Checkmate the
white Bishop defends its queen and the
king is trapped in the corner
so yeah really interesting uh idea here
I guess after taking the black queen
could just move run away I'm not sure
where to this Square maybe maybe the
square
but uh yeah it's looking really
dangerous for black now especially on
this diagonal
it was so close to chat mate already
actually wow white just needs a bit more
ammunition maybe you can Shuffle this
Rook across and bring uh The Rook to the
seventh rank crash through there and we
see levona ronian still upping I mean
it's still so quick so Swift
this position is on the board and uh
will white decide to put his Rook on
this open file to me this looks the most
natural but I guess black can defend
against any infiltration with the Rook
uh he can maybe Retreat his Rook or use
his Bishop to defend this Square
still in the balance White's king is not
entirely safe either and Black's Bishop
at least has a Target
later in the game this Pawn is a bit
weak yeah and there's I mean now I I can
see a pawn break in the long term that
black has and this is again when you're
playing in the opening you've got to
know your Pawn structures and there's a
Pawn on the what do we call it Charles
file now I guess the Charles file this
yeah this Charlie Charlie the cat's file
I think yeah yeah it's got to be officer
Charlie the cat and at some point that
pawn coming forward could be could be
very powerful in an ending just to get a
get a past Pawn but it does look at the
moment Pleasant for Magnus right because
there's beautiful Bishop striking across
the board so
um be a little bit careful if you're
live here yeah so this is the current
position let's see what Magnus comes up
with I'm expecting this to remove but
plenty of choice now great question I
see on the screen by Abel his
three-year-old kid is able to name the
pieces but that doesn't seem to know how
to move them any suggestions three years
old that's a yeah young kids yeah it is
a very young kid it so I've had success
with my nieces not necessarily by kind
of teaching them the rules or anything
because they're so young but by making
it a story and an adventure and I really
like the African way of kind of like
naming the pieces so instead of kind of
like using War analogies I mean they
just use the animals and you know they
talk about the Rooks being rhinos and I
can't remember the other animals but you
know you could just have fun and use
your imagination and that's what kids
need to do you know three years old is
so young that I think it's okay to kind
of bend the rules and just have fun
explore you know it's it's such a
pleasure to be learning at that age
I uh remember Henry Carlson told me that
when Magnus was around that age maybe
four years old he would play against
Magnus and his sister Magnus and his
sister would have all the pieces and
Henrik would have the king and the pawn
I think and he would still win yeah
queening that one Pawn he had and I
tried that yeah it didn't work he
absolutely did not work they weren't
like throwing the pieces at me so I mean
it was not a success yeah so you know I
I didn't work in my experience but you
know yeah you know they're young yeah
get creative but as an inspiration even
Magnus Carlsen has lost against only a
king and a pawn with all his pieces
that's a nice image for all of us and we
did have some moves on the board and
Magnus has taked down under two minutes
yeah so as predicted Magnus moved his
Rook across the two white Rooks are
doubled up nicely but where are they
going they don't really have any great
quests jumping to I was gonna say I
attempted fate commentators curse this
is a trick he's trying to break through
on the back rank but there's no
immediate threat
um we should mention the trick here is
that White's Rook cannot really be
captured uh or it can't be captured
twice at least if you take White's Rook
it looks like uh free bait here a free
piece but if you take it with the Queen
the second time you get deflected away
again from the key G7 square and
Checkmate the king trapped in the corner
so you cannot run away with the black
queen anywhere therefore you shouldn't
take the Rook you shouldn't touch it and
Lavon just shuffles his King across
he's just asking what are you
threatening Magnus if you trade off my
Rook I will happily drop the bishop back
and recapture and actually blacks Bishop
guards the key Square now it's all about
this G7 Square I feel yeah yeah and now
there's a threat right of uh Bishop
takes porn on the board I think the
problem for Magnus might be that a lot
of the endings so if the Queens come off
if Pieces come off they're just going to
be very bad for white here so Magnus
does have this pressure against the pawn
he's using his pieces uh well at the
moment but if you can imagine the
Queen's coming off and you look at the
pawns I'm looking at White's Queen side
pawns and they look very weak to me and
I'd imagine in an ending uh Iranian
would have very good winning chances
actually so it's kind of the short-term
play that Magnus has against I think
Lev's long-term play but can Magnus keep
this keep this up can he keep the
threats going I don't see how he can
keep this short term play up okay he now
comes to just nibble The Rook another
tactical move there yeah keeping an eye
on this piece again if okay the black
Rook moves but again if you grab White's
Rook then the BlackRock Falls check next
move the bishop drops as well so let's
catch up with the game instead black
moved this loose Rook brought it down to
the second Rank and we saw a trade of
pieces suddenly this piece is under Fire
I'm expecting Magnus to plant that in
the center of the board you could make
an argument for just kind of retreating
it tucking it away in the corner safely
he Retreats it this way wow I guess he
wants to defend this somewhat loose Pawn
but now Simon you mentioned this Pawn
break it's gonna come Charlie the
seaport's gonna advance for example if
white does nothing uh oh look at the bar
you guys jumping up for Lavon yeah maybe
this is the this is why maybe this one
push maybe the rook's gonna come yeah
look at Levon stretching as well flexing
I think he's seen that he's got some
chances I mean there's two very tempting
moves there and this is the kind of
danger that I I was mentioning okay
White's initiative has kind of died down
there's not any tactical threats and
black on the queen side is very strong I
mean Black's Pawn were quite near that
Rook is not far away from queening it's
only three squares and this is this is I
mean losing with white in the first game
is a big deal because you know winning
the blackie and someone like Lev not
easy and um it's not looking good I mean
Magnus has been uncomfortable throughout
this game I felt he's never seen
comfortable at any moment during his
game uh and I think he's just getting
outplayed actually
um feels like he's not fully warm yet it
feels like he's trying to play himself
back into gear and one minute on the
clock against ten and with a big
disadvantage and probably just losing a
pawn for free I don't really see why
this isn't dropping off okay Levon shoes
is the other option we mentioned maybe
even stronger now uh look at this Pawn
you mentioned it Simon yeah Bertie the B
Pawn or Barry Barry the B1 or best of
beep one either way this Pawn is very
strong and it's only three point uh
three squares away yeah from promotion
do you think it's a good idea like
before a very important match like this
that you you play some games so maybe
you could play stockfish you know have
some games play for you know just get
into the right kind of Rhythm because
Magnus has seemed a bit Yeah like you
said he hasn't gone in the gear and that
B Pawn is so strong now push it just
push it I mean I totally agree you know
it's three squares from becoming a queen
you know if you get another queen it's
game over and this would be a very very
uh big start for aronian in the match
and what does white even do in the
meantime the black king is super safe
right now it takes two or three moves to
even create a threat against that black
king and that black pawn only takes two
or three moves to promote so it's a race
but it looks like black is winning this
race quite easily he has all the Time in
the World to calculate the right moves
live on is it now all about moving that
b point would you move that B Pawn
already now in this move yeah I think
you just have to make sure your king is
guarded at all times or within contact
with the black queen but if that's a
good push the people push it towards its
destination
definitely
I mean I mean I'm trying to look for
ways that white can create contemplating
Magnus they're shaking his head he knows
he's in big trouble on the board and
clock the only okay Levon attacks the
White Queen this might be clever I was
going to say the only way white can ever
break through to the black king is to
push the white F Pawn forward to try and
open up lines there
still needs a miracle but right now
bigger dilemma where to put the White
Queen she has to stay within touching
distance of a bishop the black queen is
keeping an eye on that white Bishop so
the White Queen has to go to a passive
Square defensive Square I think that's
only one square right it can go to
I'm thinking the G4 Square because if
you step down to the F2 Square then the
bishop gets out and looks
quite unpleasant this is a deadly I love
that English understatement there
completely losing and it's like you know
it's very English like it looks a little
bit uncomfortable there you know it's
like yeah but now this is a Czech and a
really nasty check because the King has
to move and
again you could as levonne iranian's
doing it's all about the pins today this
queen is undefended so hit the bishop in
front of it and the bishop can't move
otherwise the queen will drop
how do you defend your Bishop if you
have to defend it with a pawn then
suddenly The Black Queen swoops in and
gets to the king this wins because the
next movement Rook will drop
how do you defend your Bishop do you
really have to put your Rook behind it
White's pieces he does this white piece
is now the rook and queen are completely
tied down levenarian upping the pressure
everything is targeted at this bishop
right now in eight seconds for Magnus
and his position is creaking maybe he
just has to throw caution to the wind
give something up and try to initiate
chaos but as it stands his position is
dire yeah look at levonne though he's
just trading off all the pieces he gives
a check next move he'll take the rook
and then he's going to just push this
Pawn he's got he's got rid of all of
White's attacking potential and uh in
this current position
is it time to just push this Pawn I mean
just give a check first you could give a
check it's got to be just a little bit
careful of that movie mentioned earlier
right David if he can stop White's got
only one idea and the one idea is to
push that pawn threatened Checkmate
against Black's King and open up the
queen to get to the back rank you know
this is just the one boost so Lev very
wisely he's got 10 minutes he's just got
to find a way to stop that one idea if
he stops that one idea he's got the pass
Pawn that's the only passport on the
board and that will become a second
Queen and win the game so he's just got
to think how to do that take your time
now you don't okay he doesn't bother he
doesn't even need to take his time he's
stopping that pawn from moving
um with actually what looks like a very
clever move there I think this is good
uh technique here you know he just
guards the king controls all whites
checks and instead for and then you know
when he's done that then he will focus
on pushing the pawn you know you don't
need to rush with it he's going to go
one point up Magnus had nothing to do
you can't push this Pawn forward any
Queen trade will for white because this
Pawn will just promote so you can't
trade Queens you have to drop back and
now you can just gobble up a pawn with a
check I mean it's not completely
hopeless I'd say because I mean Magnus
is known to be an amazing with quick
well and everything but with his queens
and there's always always chances
there's some Perpetual check
um in in this kind of ending so it's not
completely over yet that's why I'm a big
fan of just finding the king a good
hiding place and once you do that then
you can focus on pushing the pawn for me
I would think that the H7 Square looks
like it could be safe yeah but white is
threatening to go and win that very
important B Pawn we've been talking
about White Queen was threatening to go
sit next to it with a check and then
pick it off the board so Levon he's
prevented most checks with that last
queen move but uh okay the White Queen
is coming in the White Queen wants to go
up diagonally to the top rank to the
eighth rank check that black king
and some chances yeah the bar is going a
little bit down you mentioned Perpetual
check Simon if we do have any beginners
out there should we explain Perpetual
check definitely yeah Perpetual check is
um if you repeat the same position three
times at any moment during the game then
you can claim a draw because it's like
basically showing it no progress has
been made let's have a draw so it's just
repeating three times and the way that
white uh would love to do this here is
by using his Queen to attack Black's
King and then let's say we don't even
need to show it on the board but let's
say the black king moves you you just
repeat by checking it and then you get
your draw and obviously Magnus being a
pawn down this is the kind of thing he's
aiming for with his last move the queen
is getting ready to uh to try and check
attack the black king uh so this is this
is the one hope Black's king is not
completely safe it only has two
bodyguards in front of it the pawns it
could do with like a third bodyguard to
stop those checks
um so you know there's a bit of work to
do here yeah of course it should be
winning but you've got to be accurate
here and Magnus very very good with this
Queens yeah
it's actually really tricky I'm trying
to even find a move now for black but
struggling uh the idea is well a threat
right now for white if black does
nothing if black creates this ideal
hiding place for his King he wants to do
this as Ivanka mentioned the problem is
timing this check hits the king and when
it hides suddenly Black's Best Pawn is
eliminated if this B Pawn is eliminated
Black's winning chances also disappear
because in this position no more pass
pawns three pawns versus three pawns
dead draw so this is a really nasty
threat uh this queen check and how do
you stop it if you if you're careless go
back for example to stop that check
suddenly the black king gets checkmated
so we could see a turnaround instead
levonaroni and of course spots that made
in one idea he gives a check another
trap if the king walked forward for
white then black can trade off the
Queen's track and swapping off the White
Queen but the king can go back and it
hides and now Levon goes the whole way
back
defending against any checks on this
back rank just keeping the black king
safe for now but Magnus he's insisting
he really wants this Pawn
he's trying to get it if you push it
forward now then again a check
the pawn drops off he's just making life
difficult Magnus right now the
evaluation Bar says it's winning for
black but you still have to be really
careful you need to keep this Pawn alive
what a start to this quarterfinal match
between Magnus and Levon one game and
one quart final has already finished
it's a really bad start for Hans Neiman
with the white pieces he lost game one
two Liam he will now have to make a
comeback to take it to tie breaks or
even win the match very bad start for
Hans Neiman and Magnus as well with a
white pieces struggling here
ah struggling but the one thing I
I don't really approve of is how quickly
levon's playing he's got seven and a
half minutes as we mentioned he had a
winning position probably still but
I mean playing moves like this where
he's just allowed a check just given up
a pawn now white has a very strong past
Pawn but the queen can go behind the
pawn and uh that's straightforward plan
Beth is marching but now it's it's a
race uh it does look very strong
actually this last move
people how do we stop it it's a nice
move there because black could have
actually taken a pawn with check using a
little sequence there but that doesn't
go for it those pawns near White's King
completely irrelevant in Queen endings
it's all about having a pawn which is
not obstructed so if you get your queen
behind that non-obstructive pawn you
just you just launch it all the way down
and it is is true I mean black has a
very easy plan and hit surely he's going
to push the pawn now here it comes two
squares away just two that's not a lot
yes I have a word I have this expression
I've taken it's quality over quantity
when it comes to pawns and end games and
life yeah I think you don't yeah
definitely I don't know I believe in
quantity
is good read is good they both have
three pawns so is it and now Magnus is
also moving his whoa upwards is it that
one square that the black porn is
further up than the white yeah exactly
the whole difference
yeah it should do but I mean it's it's I
mean he can push the pawn again and
white will only have one move and it's a
really ugly move which I'm we'll
probably see anyway yeah
um but you then got to find like find
what to do next yeah black is about to
promote so white has to come back and
block
so how do you get rid of this blockader
I guess one idea would be to bring the
queen in
I'm not sure exactly where but white
pushes the pawn the queen moves white
Pawn pushes and after a check white is
just in time to move the king and it's
important that this promotes and it will
be Checkmate once white makes a new
Queen and uh okay black hasn't gone for
this uh it looks like white was doing
okay here White's just in time with the
race instead if we go back black didn't
push his Pawn he just created some space
for this black king
that loses a valuable move
now will white start pushing this Pawn
on the next move it's Black's turn right
now but great defense from Magnus and I
I can see this heading towards the draw
because uh the thing is if you remove
the pawns on the left hand side which
could easily happen because white can
use his Pawn to distract Black's Queen
away it should definitely be a draw then
so I'd imagine he's going to move his
Pawn up and he's trying to force the
black queen to a bad square and actually
even without we get to some weird ending
even without white spawns on the king
side those positions can be drawn even
if you're two pawns up second Magnus has
just stepped his King forward and that
allows I mean takes Pawn check what is
this I don't understand that oh why did
he do that he just Why is he dropped a
pawn with check and the running hasn't
spotted it yet what I mean take a pull
in the chair come on it's not just a
pawn with track but when the king moves
the queen comes in yeah he has seen it
what's that done is he resigning
suddenly resigns Magnus just a one move
blunder oh what a horrible start to the
day four minus causing